why do you say that you weren't what you
thought was quote unquote good enough
to make it at that time
I don't think I was disciplined enough
there's something that comes with
discipline
when you when you have
the struggle and then you have the lack
of knowledge you're winging it
and in life
you can't get anywhere with wing in it
there's some things you can get into or
get access to that you're not supposed
to by winging it but if you want to
succeed
I say look at whoever it is and dissect
backwards and create a plan because the
more that you have a plan the more
likely you are to succeed so if your
plan is
hey
um I want to be an Uber driver then you
know like okay I have to download this
app I have to send this information I
have to get qualified I have to go
through their courses and then I have to
go uh and then I get qualified to be an
Uber driver and then I pick up people
and drop them off okay so there was a
plan there so if you want to make it as
an actor
what's the plan oh I'm just going to
show up well
for the the lottery person that may work
but for the majority of us you have to
ask yourself okay outside of everybody
wanting to be Brad Pitt right let's just
take that off the table for a second
okay what kind of career do you want to
have
do you want to have a career as a
commercial actor do you want to have a
career as uh a theatrical actor a movie
TV okay well who's the casting director
for your favorite shows what are they
looking for
um what's the look what's the tone right
if you're looking to go into movies
where and I say all that because as an
actor you're really taking anything that
comes to you right if you're in that
circuit any audition commercial TV film
you're just you just you're so hungry
and so desperate for a job that you'll
take anything Union non-union it doesn't
matter
but if you're able to create a plan
the tunnel the light becomes so much
clearer
so
for example
and this this isn't the greatest example
but I had an agent in LA right I mean
not La Atlanta right now I'm agentless
no agent no manager no anything I kind
of
bypassed all of that but I had an agent
in Atlanta and I knew that I wasn't a
good client to have
because I turned down 95 of the
auditions that came in because I had the
stability of a career
I didn't need the jobs when you don't
need the jobs you become picky
so now by having a plan and a goal I
knew the roles that I wanted to play I
knew the projects that I wanted to be a
part of were projects that sounded
interesting to what I like and just
interesting in general I no longer
needed to just apply and be accepted to
anything out there because I didn't need
the money from the job albeit whether
it's a commercial or an acting job
because I had a career over here
there's power and strength in that
because now there is no desperation
there is no
um hey let's just send Jason out to
audition for this gas station guy like
how does that benefit me in my career I
can't have one line you can give that to
anybody you don't have to audition for
you can just give it to anybody give it
to a PA on set hey can you say this line
yeah absolutely right
so when you have a plan and you're able
to just kind of go from step one to two
to three to four
the likelihood of you getting there
sooner
is a lot greater
how many times do you think you heard
the word no while you were in Los
Angeles
every time I would say my my booking
rate was probably I would if I'm going
to be fair I would say probably about
three to five percent
so out of every hundred I booked maybe
three to five
um
which in hindsight isn't bad and I would
say about 85 percent of it 85 percent of
the time I would get callbacks
and those are the most crushing
because I'd rather just get a no than to
get your hope up that you could get it
they called you back like Power Rangers
I went to like five auditions and you
could possibly get it and then they're
like nah no I you know I'd prefer to
just you know cut me off at the door but
yeah I would say
no is probably the greatest thing
to
make you as a human being stronger
because when you realize that every no
is just closer yes they're just little
things that come and come go out the way
to get to that yes
you welcome the nose I welcome those
it's okay because I'm gonna talk to the
next guy I'm gonna talk to the next guy
I'm going to talk to the next guy until
I get the yes
that's what's changed with being a
filmmaker compared to wanting to be an
actor
if you're someone out there that's a
creative
you spend so much time wanting to get on
set
whether it's background work because
that's how I started I started going
background work
um a one-liner
maybe a day player
if you look back on it and you spend all
those years just to get on set what
happens if you would have created a plan
to create your own set
how would that have turned out and
create the project and the role that you
want to be a part of that you want to
see and then be in a position to give
other people opportunities
in all of my films majority of the
actors are first time second time actors
with not a lot of credits and I make
sure that if I say hey do you want to be
a part of this project and they say yes
and let's say in the script I only have
one line for them I'll make sure to go
back and write two three four five lines
so they really feel like they were a
part of the project and not just there
to kind of make a cameo
right so
I just think that as a creative it's
important to
create the
films
that you want to see and you want to be
a part of compared to wearing so much
about trying to get on set
I think it can change the dynamic for a
lot of people because if you think about
it social media has changed everything
for people our age that were born in the
70s 80s like yeah we grew up with the
Hollywood star for us it's the Stars
right
for the newer generation it's the social
media influencers they're the Stars
so
you can create your star
at home in Kentucky
it doesn't matter where you are you can
become a star you push record and you do
something every day and just be
consistent with it and I would challenge
anybody I'm not good at this I don't do
it but I would challenge anybody if you
put on your calendar right now say I
want to be a influencer right and for
365 days without missing a day you post
something about something I can
guarantee you that account that's at
zero in a year if you did it every day
without missing a day
that you will be way further than you
are today now the issue with that is
comes back to responsibility to the
human self how many people are going to
stick to that every day and be
disciplined because there's power and
discipline to do that every single day
not make excuses and not miss it
because I don't do it every day I'm
quite frankly I because I grew up in
that era which I think is the best ERA
for films 80s 90s like hands down the
best ERA for films and entertainment
um that's what I enjoy doing so that's
what I spend my time doing I'm not into
social media as much as I should be
because that's where everything is now
um
yeah I would say if you want to make it
you want to do it
start with your phone start at home
create it because then you get enough of
a following they're going to come to you
anyways
in hindsight do you wish you had left
Los Angeles earlier
yes and no uh I want to say no because
that led me to meeting my wife which uh
then we had our son
but yes because
it's not even leaving La sooner it's
creating sooner
I would I don't want to say wish because
wish makes it seem like you're looking
at some third entity to do something for
you
it would have been nice
to
create
sooner create the roles
that I wanted to see that I wanted to be
a part of sooner
that would have been nice and I think
that would have changed a lot because
for anybody out there
once you do your first film
whatever you thought was hard whatever
you thought was difficult whatever you
thought was impossible is gone
because when you can complete it once
you can complete it twice then each time
you do it it becomes easier and easier
so when I did the first film by no means
is it an Oscar film is it is it well
written because I'm not the best writer
I don't put commas in periods where they
should be I kind of just write and this
is the story and this is what we're
gonna do I don't do 10 drafts I do maybe
two just to kind of check it
once you get that first film out you
learn where you make mistakes
you learn the focal length that you'd
like to shoot it and that you don't like
to shoot at you kind of learn your style
right so getting that first film Out is
more important for you as a human being
and as a Creator to let yourself know
like I can do this and I can do it and
get better every single day and I can
keep creating
than it is for you to create a
masterpiece of a film because I'd rather
have
10 average 5 Star films then to have one
masterpiece and the reason for that is
because if you think of the economy of
actors writers producers grips Pas the
whole economy of making one film if I'm
able to do 10 that are average films I
gave them a lifeline
of 10. I gave actors and actresses the
opportunity to be a part of 10 films
compared to one
and you live and you grow and you and
and as time goes on
when you make films it's now an
experience because you've made them
compared to watching them when you watch
a film or you watch a TV show there's
this ah there's this magic to it that
you're like oh wow that would be great
then when you make it and you start
making it and you start making film one
film two TV series web series
it's not that the magic leaves the magic
of the lens changes
where now
you're not looking for someone to give
you an opportunity
you're able to give other people
opportunities
and I can tell you from my films
how many actors
have started creating their own projects
and that in itself is so rewarding
because by them looking at you and
seeing you do it
they look at themselves and say well if
he can do it with that I could do it too
and that is so rewarding and that I
think is a game changer
what's your advice for let's say an 18
year old graduated
High School comes to LA with really no
no plan but also they're leaving a
situation where they didn't have a
choice Maybe
how do they keep themselves creative how
do they keep themselves safe okay so
that's that's a really good question I
think that
stay away from anything that looks easy
uh
stay away from
hey why don't you come live with me
where is that coming from what's the
ulterior alternative motor uh what is
the ulterior motive there
um
I would say go back to school
even if it's worth even if you have to
take that loan because you'll make that
back and I don't say go back to school
for film go back to school for something
that you know makes money
because having that those funds they're
going to help you create they're going
to help you be
a better version of yourself
so
stay away from drugs stay away from
parties stay away from situations where
you are not your coherent self
and write two goals
write your goal on okay
how do I get to where I want to be
whether that's a writer on the fox lot
whether that's a producer or director
okay
who can I shadow
or who can I contact to Mentor me
because they'll give you insight and
information that'll get you there a lot
sooner than you trying to figure it out
um
how can I stay grounded and true to
myself
you know
a lot of times you hear people
talk about
oh
this person
you know sold their soul or anything
like that right something crazy
but I think what really happens is
when you're young and you don't have a
choice and you're just trying to survive
I think you do things that as you get
older and you grow as a person
that you weren't proud of
and I think that as you get older it
sits on your conscious and it eats you
and I think that's more of the Soldier's
Soul than anything else
and I would say to stay strong to who
you are at the core as a human being
because when I was 18 and I was out here
there were opportunities where it's like
hey yeah come stay with me right
and I never took up those opportunities
but it kept my conscience so clean
and the objective of and the goal of
what I was trying to do so
strong that even though I quit
acting after
15 years
or it was like 12 12 to 15 years I don't
remember exactly but even though I quit
at that audition
I didn't it didn't take away the fire of
wanting to be a part of something great
and the magic of
film
is that you're able to inspire someone
at home
whether they're in India or they're in
Georgia
you're able to
spread that magic
to someone else
you're able to
live forever within that space of time
so
when you create a film and you star in
it you co-star in it and you're on that
screen
it's almost like a legacy capture piece
because your kids your grandkids will
always be able to look at you in that
time and space and say look at my dad or
my granddad that was him
and I think that alone is such a magical
thing
um about film and I know I kind of went
off from the advice I would give the 18
year old but I that goes back to me
saying stay true to yourself
don't compromise who you are that
doesn't mean that you you you don't have
to bend and you have to give because in
any even marriage or relationship and a
career is kind of like a relationship
there's a given a take
but you don't compromise in your core
values as a human being in your Pursuit
of anything